mom come on daddy
look at this
if you don't mind i don't look at this
look at him i mean now this moment this
man is having a moment this man
great year for you how are you i am so
good to see you um i love those shoes
about to say where am i
let me just give you the money
to her see you we just spoke on
ourselves we did we did not too long ago
i mean you're so sensitive
you guys are both nominated in the same
categories yes we're doing it all
together yeah yeah is it together or is
it like it's love you but no i've
actively campaigned for people to vote
yeah crazily enough he's been like
really going hard to get people to vote
for me not not crazy enough but it's
very surprising to me that morning
it's your genuine self you know what i
mean so it's not so crazy but i was
definitely surprised but that was very
touching and it was a cumulative that
was so easy and natural for me to do it
i wanted to return the favor but i was
like i'd be biting this style if i just
was like no i've overblown but like
already sets the best example for
everybody who works there and so it was
it was so so so easy
i appreciate that the season's coming
back october 2nd everybody is everybody
coming back
okay well then if they can say that then
that means they're coming back okay oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah i'll be there i
think it's good yeah you're good at it
you're good at it you've been doing it
as well recently again for the first
time and like you were fantastic with
that anyway monique got after him though
didn't she whoo
all right keenan's coming yeah yeah yeah
yes tell us about season two is coming
up and also norm mcdonald i want to ask
you guys real quick about norman
oh yeah it's all happening i mean we're
sad about that but you know
at least there's no more pain i guess
you know and
the comedy world definitely uh took a
big shot for that one
look at billy because i can't afford it
i've been looking look at billy i've
been looking the whole time i lose it so
i'm taking these big rings off go talk
to philly hold on i'm gonna give you
good luck tonight it's great to see you